whoever breaks the most laws wins i love
breaking the law
here's how it works every time you break
a law you get one point whoever breaks
the most
loss before this timer hits zero i will
give their dad a ten thousand dollar
chipotle gift card yo
my dad's gonna be so happy that's a lot
of beans and whoever breaks the least
amount of laws has to do 100 burpees
gentlemen are you ready ready you have
one hour
starting now go break the law all right
be notified old lady
all right so i hit an old lady and i
shot a cop that's breaking two laws now
i'm going to steal a cop car
that's breaking a third all right
driving on sideways breaking the law
all right i just shot someone in the
head jayla aren't you super happy that
watchdogs was gracious enough to sponsor
this video yes i love this game and we
get to play it early we're cooler than
everybody because we played it before
you
put a little tap tap to the head hey
killing a man with a head shot is a law
stealing a car looks like it's illegal
trey how many laws have i broken you've
broken two trey is hacking into
somebody's vehicle and making it slam
into somebody
against the law yeah in fact i think
that's two at one time trey i'm beating
up people left and right i think i've
broken three laws
i already have broken three laws jimothy
wait try try it
double parking oh look at that
i shot a firearm in the city killed a
person stole the ambulance
driving on the wrong side of the road
he's driving on the wrong side of the
low that's another role
how many losses chandler broke up
chandler's broken seven right now how
about carl seven
six oh oh he just stole a car that's
another one all right seven seven
you see that trash right there littering
driving on a sidewalk i mean that's a
lot of me how many laws has chris broken
we've broken eight so everyone's on
eight what about tyler
seven tyler you're in last place i know
i was gonna stay that way probably
i just learned how to uncrouch
jaywalking
write it down ah how do i litter how do
i litter
this trash can will not break kill me
kill me i can just recruit anyone on the
side of the road and they'll join my
criminal empire
all right this guy looks like a good
recruit you're recruited as you remember
in this video and what you're seeing
here you can recruit
and play as anyone in london there are
so many high value characters in watch
dogs legions and they each have their
own unique skills
and in watch dogs legions you can build
your own unique team of resistant heroes
to take back london find and build a
team that matches your playstyle
i shot a government vehicle out start a
recruitment mission i'm recruiting uh
for a government legal
crime organization sounds against the
law to me hey
hey get over here i'm going to recruit
you oh
i just got a civilian shot it's got to
be illegal wait trey if i go
liberate a freedom fighter isn't that
illegal all right let's go
uh-oh hacked somebody's phone sounds
like another illegal thing to do
trey i'm recruiting somebody that's
illegal chris you want to know what else
is illegal what
punching tray trey it looks like i'm not
supposed to go in this building right
oh look at this here i go driving on a
bridge illegally
this reminds me of fortnite how does it
remind you of fortnite
i don't know it's the only shooter game
i played it's been a while with me just
hanging out over here
loitering trey is this illegal it feels
illegal
what are you doing i'm driving through
somebody's backyard oh god i didn't mean
to give you i didn't mean to hurt you i
already did that law
i just tried to open a door and i just
swaying at it yeah i just stole
military vehicles that is a big wall
broken hacking
a literal street now that sounds illegal
to me i'm hacking everything
i control the law i don't know anything
illegal i don't know how to play it i
was taught not to break the law
i'm stealing a boat purposefully jumping
in front of a bus
i mean that smells illegal to me i'm
stealing a boat
i'm committing piracy isn't that two
crimes
oh i haven't jumped out of a moving
vehicle yet wait is vehicular
manslaughter different on the water
no i think that's still killing okay
that's fair i don't know how to jump out
of this car
i just want to jump out of the car i'm
going over the speed limit on the wrong
side of the road
uh passing red lights oh my gosh does
this guy have newspapers for sale
definitely can't take that for free
we're driving on land even though it
won't let me but we're kind of doing it
i'm a pro driver at this
i feel like i'm so far behind i'm so
sorry dad how many lots has chris broken
20. tyler tyler you might as well just
quit now
uh no i'm actually gonna try what was me
i almost missed out on
illegal activity such as driving a car
into a subway
whoa smells illegal how many lost this
car broke in 24
chandler 23. oh my gosh so you're in
first place congrats
i stole intelligence highly illegal how
do i pull up my phone and get into the
wi-fi
oh wait it says oh look at this can't go
this way it looks like it just broke
another law
you know what i might lose but i just
want to jump off a building that's my
goal right now
all right let's go back here there's got
to be some laws that need to be broken
back here
fleeing cops and getting away with it is
illegal
ah forklift destruction you can't do
anything
actually a forklift does require a
different license so this different laws
broken oh
that's like three laws right there oh my
gosh i just want to jump off the
building and there's no stairs
oh excuse me
i broke your 16 laws 27.
[Music]
i'll put my box on for safety this is
just fun this is like i could take all
my anger out in a video game driving a
boat
onto the ground baby nothing legal about
that
i don't think it's actually illegal to
put your boat on land yo
chandler how is your law breaking
experience going it's going quite well
i've uh destroyed this
this uh storefront ah trey this has got
to be illegal
technically if you die in parliament
that's illegal really yes
okay i went online and i printed off a
bunch of easy laws you guys can break
use that as a reference now you're
showing me this while i'm in last place
wait there's a list bro i was just doing
stuff chris now that you have this list
what are you doing
i'm going to go graffiti did you get
that from the list i did it said i can i
get a fist one probably
thank you buddy jump it off a building
wait jumping off of a building is
illegal jumping off a building
extraordinarily illegal
okay well let me do the spray paint
first and then i'll jump off a building
how i've been trying to jump off a
building the whole
time tyler you're almost twice as far
behind third place
wait am i really that far chris is at 30
they're in the 30s tyler you're not even
close anymore
gentlemen oh
20 minutes remain 20 yes 20 minutes
they're getting a little complacent
let's spice things up both you
stop what you're doing and switch
computers carry the walls over though
but you got to switch computers
you literally have a boat now chris
congratulations thanks for the boat bro
yeah you literally have a boat oh wait
you're right by
water i'm fine also your character ugly
i'm just gonna be honest all right stop
what you're doing
you two have to switch computers i
really don't know where i'm at who is
this woman
yo some dude just punching me out of
nowhere carl what'd you leave me with
trey i hacked this or i'm in the boat
all right just shoot something someone
oh
i'm a pirate i win even though chandler
put me in the worst spot possible
i got back off of pure skill and
definitely not fast traveling
i'm jumping off a building if it's the
last thing i do i'm doing it is it
illegal to punch a porta potty
don't call it a comeback when you guys
run out of laws i'm gonna win
hey a tree is this illegal no that's why
you're in last
as of right now carl you're in first
place chandler you're in second place
and chris you're in third place and
tyler you're in last
i have no idea as of right now you're
gonna have to do 100 burpees and carl's
gonna get ten thousand dollars for
chipotle for his father
i'm getting it gentlemen less than ten
minutes remain i'm sorry dad i failed
you
no i've been decapitated trey my dying
wishes just jump off the building i just
to do that here let me help you trey is
it illegal to get a cop
stuck inside of something because i
raised something uh
no yes trey get me to that building tray
impersonating a policeman because i
turned on the sirens that's illegal
okay so i stole a drone right and now
i'm gonna
drop the cargo on this guy right here
this has got to be a different kind of
law broken
that is raining packages from above
that's illegal yep
five minutes okay trey are you playing
for him he's trying to get me to a
building
yes yes yes yes did we just break the
law yeah he broke the law hey trey how
many lives am i behind
five wait i'm only five behind chris
yeah but there's five minutes left
there's no more loss to break i've gone
through the list wait wait whoa
stop sign watch this well that's for
cars
oh let me get a car let me get a car two
minutes left you each have 39. how many
does chris have
two minutes how does that was a green
light oh my gosh i went through a green
light i'll wait for it to turn red two
minutes left there 40 39 christian
around 35 chris if you do not break like
seven laws right now
you won't win i've run out of things to
do i'm only down by three
chris if he breaks three laws the next
two minutes before you break any laws
then you have to do a hundred burpees oh
my gosh
i should have been a worse kid one
minute remaining
oh my gosh come on don't don't kill me
don't kill me don't kill me tyler i'm
pretty confident you're gonna lose i'm
gonna go watch the other guys
that's fair i made the bus i hacked the
bus how many losses you broken 41
carl 39 39. 40 seconds tomorrow to break
two laws
there's no more laws that isn't just
cheese in it check me out check me out
hold on
i'm driving with broken headlights oh my
goodness you're actually kind of smart
man
15 seconds left 15 seconds carl are you
the biggest friend 12 seconds carl to
pick it away
with the broken windshield okay you
still have eight seconds
no more toweling stuff controller down i
didn't
tyler came in last with 32 laws broken
have fun with 100 burpees and then
chandler i mean
first place call your dad uh so we just
did a gaming challenge and i won ten
thousand dollars ten thousand dollars
chipotle for you tyler has to do burpees
because he lost yeah check out what
tyler won
i don't know is this korean yeah do you
even like chipotle yes
all right well perfect are you gonna get
all 100
[Music]
this game is a lot of fun and i highly
recommend if you like video games that
you give watchdog legions a try thank
you so much watchdog legions for
sponsoring this video
i appreciate it